[Musique]
c'est ici que tout a commencé et je vais
vous raconter une partie de l'histoire
du tourisme à la réunion en 1946 à la
départementalisation
j'ai 18 ans des pâtes modernisation ne
savais pas ce que ça vous le dire très
honnêtement on nous a expliqué que sa
cave et ceux ci il y avait ceux là qui
allait changer notre amendant la
perception des impôts et des charges
sociales
il ya bien un vrai pas tout la réunion
qui était pour mai mais très vite on n'a
vu l'autre côté qui a rêvé la lame de
fond avec cnn etc
et puis tout est rentré très vite
c'est le premier fanion diamants reçus
ensuite c'est la france et la suisse
vers madagascar c'est le développement
jeu purement et simplement je me suis
dit que ça n'est que dans le tourisme
quand on voit quelque chose avec mon
beau-frère on a beaucoup parlé de ça et
puis j'étais très ami de tous les grands
patrons les touristes en maurice mingant
et compagnie je voyais que ils pouvaient
j'étais d'un sucre leur argent était
dans le sucre mais il commençait déjà à
mettre de côté dans le tourisme nous n'a
fait qu'une part nous ne savions comment
dirais-je gérer notre développement nous
on a fait le récif et ensuite après on a
fait les créoles les brison et ensuite
le villas du lagon qui ne dupe guy
dupont a beaucoup peiné et là dedans
c'est chez nouvelles frontières avec son
apport de clientèle
on ne peut pas faire ça ce n'est pas
possible nous n'aurions pas pu arriver à
un tel développement
si nous avions une autre statut que
celui de département
regardez autour de vous n'ont pas fini
leur pend dans dans la réunion
d'aujourd'hui qui va renaître du
quotidien
l'eau nous allons connaître un boom et
là il faudra avoir les outils on
semblait être parti dans la bonne
direction
le déparement été joués taylor et le
département a toujours aidé ceux qui ont
voulu ignorer s'il a bénéficié des
premières et pour les premières aides
départementales
c'était peu c'est pas grand chose mais
c'était l'idée de départ pour qu'ils
avaient la région n'existait pas ou si
peu
voyez mon bureau il évite de tous je ne
sais pas taper sur henin sur un clavier
mais j'étais habitué à gérer d'une autre
manière
les jeunes ils sont aussi critiques
tacatac tout le temps ils savent comment
faire et ils savent où aller piocher les
idées clocher les renseignements ce que
je ne savais pas faire
à partir de là tout est possible
eux mêmes vont être source de
développement c'est clair madame frécaut
et ma fille
c'est la directrice générale de tout
l'ensemble beaumont voyage et c'est un
qui est maintenant siège pas tous là on
doit siéger
je suis content de ce que j'ai fait je
sais que ça a apporté beaucoup de bien à
beaucoup à beaucoup de gens autour de
moi beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup des
centaines mais c'est parfait comme ça
s'était passé dans ce but c'est arrivé
avec voilà
[Musique]